- Like, we have to start
getting into meritocracy.
Somebody should lose if they're
not seeing where
the puck is going.
If you're driving a truck
today, you know it's coming.
You've heard it.
Somebody told you at a
bus stop, at a truck stop,
over dinner, somebody
brought up this theory.
So either you take it seriously
and start educating
yourself or you don't.
That's the game.
Nobody's gonna fix that.
Nobody can help you with that.
That's life and
that's the historic nature
of human beings forever.
So just 'cause we're now living
and it's our turn to go through
something, this
has always happened.
- [Daymond] You're right.
It's just
happening faster, I think.
- Great. Adjust.
(light music)